foreign
what's up Tamara go Astros
hi Dr John how are you I'm good how are
you
I'm good awesome what's up
um
so I just have um
question so I
sort of been struggling
um with
like getting close to my stepson
and like feeling that love
for him like I should in a way
um
go tell me more
so we got custody of him like have
custody about a year ago
um and before that you know we would
just have him like every other weekend
and stuff and my husband was obviously
fighting really hard to get half custody
and uh how old is this little boy
he is seven is seven seven how long have
you been married
we have been married for two years two
years
were you previously married too
um never married I was in previous
relationship for like nine years and I
had a daughter in that relationship
um
and my daughter's eight so they're kind
of close in age
um
yeah so
whenever before we got half custody we
had like full custody
for a time because there was like the
situation situation that happened
um
and so we ended up getting full custody
for like a whole summer pretty much okay
and during that time I wasn't working so
the caretaking pretty much fell on me
okay
um and I feel like I struggled a lot my
husband and I had a lot of issues during
that time
um we almost got a divorce why why
because as you're saying this I'm
thinking this has nothing to do with
that little boy
no no during the time when we were going
to get divorced it was mostly like
Financial issues um he was like on the
Ramsey Blank gun hole about Ramsay and I
wasn't and we just had a bunch of issues
we started seeing a financial counselor
and we fixed that we pretty much got on
the same page and ever since then my
husband and I have been great but I feel
like this thing with my stepson has me
feeling
like I'm struggling
and what's what's the struggle is he
loud is he annoying is he a brat is he
is he not feeling like your daughter
feels like what is the thing you're
struggling with
um well yeah pretty much you said it
like he's just very loud
um kind of body just stuff that I'm not
used to like my with my daughter she's
just very chill very laid back
um I had all girls in my family like
nothing but sisters
um cousin pretty much girls and so I
wasn't used to voice welcome to the
terror Dome Tara Tamara
you're in it now
I know so with him I was like oh my
goodness like is this how boys I you
know he's he's a lot
um that's the exact words my wife used
to describe me
um what's it like living with John and
she
it's it's a lot it's a lot yeah yes not
every boy some boys are quiet some boys
are are do their own thing and
some boys are maniacs
yeah yeah it sounds like you have some
expectations about what you're supposed
to feel and how kids are supposed to be
and that's the issue here I don't ever
want to punish a seven-year-old boy for
being a seven-year-old boy all right let
me say punish I don't want to dislike a
seven-year-old boy for being a
seven-year-old boy
yeah exactly and I I don't I don't want
to feel that way
um I I
have divorced parents okay so I had you
know step parents um my stepdad
sort of like didn't really care for us
um you know he I to this day I've never
had a real conversation with my stepdad
like he just didn't care much for us so
will you change that
I'm sorry are you going to change that
with my stepdad nope can't can't oh yeah
that one's got appeared at the end but
now you're a step parent
yes and you get to change what happens
moving forward are you gonna are you
gonna do that
yes I want to that's why
I'm here do you ah there we go Okay so
before I walk you through it do you want
to or do you want to want to
um
because if you want to it's going to
require you to do different things
yeah if you want to want to then you
just have to wait until you decide you
actually want to make some changes in
your life
yeah
I want to okay
so I'm going to tell you something
that's hard and is not politically
correct is that cool
okay I don't care about how you feel as
the adult I care more about right now
what you do
okay
you can't compare him
to your the feelings and connection you
have with your daughter
okay it's gonna feel different
especially right now
and especially because they're so
different right
and so comparing them of total Fool's
errands man you're gonna you're gonna
you'll crash that that into the into the
ditch I call the buddy of mine who's
um has someone of a similar situation
just walk through like hey what are some
things you experience in the house what
are some things your wife experienced
that so
um comparison is what's going to kill
you the second thing is is you've got to
let completely go your preconceived
notions of what full custody was going
to mean I think you're still hanging on
you fought for for custody you were all
in until you like oh this is what a
seven-year-old boy in the house feels
like and looks like
um how does p get everywhere right how
does it get everywhere it just does
um you're gonna have to let those
preconceived notions go and let your
seven-year-old be who your
seven-year-old is
yeah my guess is that summer that you
spent
you had some preconceived notions about
that Summer's going to look like and all
of a sudden you ended up and it was July
and you were basically just a caretaker
of your new husbands
kid
and it was less about
I bet you're fun to hang out with but it
was less about that and more about I
didn't sign up for this or I had
different expectations for this and now
my life is different than I thought it
was going to be is that fair
okay
um
so I care way more about what you do
have you had like a weekly date with him
just us two
um I'm gonna take him out to for
breakfast or dinner just us too
it's been
um but yeah I I agree that I feel like I
should do more of that with him it's not
it's not big huge grand gestures it's
not like I gotta take him to Disneyland
It's not that it's the tiny little
things that he hasn't had in a long time
once uh once a week you get breakfast
with stepmom
and we're gonna pick some restaurant I
eat at Waffle House with my kid and I
literally am dying every time I have
breakfast I know this
um but the time with him is worth it
right I mean from what I'm eating but I
it's it's it's a great time with him but
it's always on the calendar and so
letting him know relationally I'm gonna
keep showing up I'm gonna invest in you
little things like hey give me a list of
books and movies you like I'm reading an
old Michael Crichton book right now
because I'm doing a book exchange with
my son
and it wouldn't have been a book that I
picked but I'm trying to get into it so
I can get into his world and I can talk
to him things he's interested in see
what I'm saying and ultimately he's
gonna remember dad invested in me dad
came to my world sometimes and didn't
always drag me along to his and so I'd
love you to make a list of music a list
of I my son the other day got in the
truck and you've probably heard me talk
about his love for 90s country I had
like a I don't know Garth Brooks or
Brooks and Dunn there I don't know CD in
my my CD player in the truck
um and he's like Dad what are you
listening to and I said I'm listening to
this because I love you
and he beamed right so you may have to
grit your teeth through some new hip-hop
artist or through some new pop country
art I don't I don't care we're gonna
teach him that I'm investing in you okay
and then the little thing would he give
you a hug every day
uh
yes
see that's what gets me sometimes
because he's so like cuddly and
you know just like very he's he's a
sweet boy
um
and sometimes I I struggle with like
feeling you know that or like
he'll come up and hug me when I get home
sometimes he'll come before my daughter
does and like give me a big hug and why
why does that why does that catch why
don't you like that
or why don't you see that for what it is
which is a little boy saying am I safe
do you love me
I don't I don't know okay
what do you feel when he hugs you
annoyed frustrated get away from me what
do you feel
um
like
I would say
just say it just you say what
maybe annoyed because I don't feel like
that connection
um
so yeah what's the what what is the
connection gonna feel like
okay
and I don't know like it does when you
know my daughter comes up to hug me or
something it will never feel like that
would you do that to a seven-year-old
like in the mall
would I
yeah or would you if a seven-year-old in
the mall or like at a church or
something came up to give you a hug
would you be like uh
um
probably
um
probably
[Laughter]
well there's never been like a really
like honey thank you for being honest so
especially person so here's a here's an
important thing
number one you can teach him boundaries
by saying
I'm not a big hugger but I do like this
let's come up with a secret handshake
together
or
um you can practice
not quote unquote feeling like a hug but
still hugging this little seven-year-old
boy anyway
okay that's what adults do
is they do the right thing even though
they quote unquote don't feel like it I
didn't feel like working out this
morning you do it anyway right yeah
um now when it comes to your body
there's a little bit that's a little bit
different so there may come Seasons when
you say I don't want him bearing his
head in my chest and I don't want him
nuzzling up on me that's fine
here's how we're going to do this
instead right so but we're not we're not
starving him and cutting him off because
right now he's wondering what was so bad
about him that his mom left
what was so bad about me that Dad made
mom go away
well he his mom is in the picture we
have half custody I guess I know and his
whole world has exploded
and he's coming to you every time saying
am I safe
yeah do you love me and your body is
telling him oh
oh seventh grade boy gross our
seven-year-old boy gross
second grader don't do that
yeah okay even if you don't feel like it
that connection with that kid doesn't
mean you have to nuzzle up to him
doesn't mean you have to like I there's
a there's a fine line here but it's
right let me ask you this hard question
um and I may be out to lunch here okay
is there something about seeing him
well let me preface it this way
um I had a girlfriend for a long time
before I got married I've been married
20 years
um and I'm friends with all all almost
all my uncle friends like I I in cordial
would say hi to them
um all that so it's not like a weird
thing
um my wife told me once
I'll always be jealous of so and so I
said why we've been married for two
decades
and the response was so insightful
and she said because she'll always have
something I don't have and I was like
what's that and she said five more years
of knowing you
She'll always be ahead of me and it
never occurred to me
um and again that jealousy is not like
she's my wife's waking up in the middle
of the night with lipstick on the right
drawing on the mirror right not nothing
like that but it's this idea like
there's always a little tiny I didn't
know you as a freshman she did in high
school I didn't know you as a weird
awkward junior in high school she did
right so is there something about
seeing this little boy
that reminds you or acknowledges that
your husband had another life before you
has to do with like
um he has a lot of his mom's qualities
like you know he's sort of like negative
he can be very negative very
um he can be a little manipulative
sometimes
um okay hold on hold on you are putting
adult
um
adult issues
on a child
yeah ex-wife may be super manipulative
seven-year-old little boys trying to
figure out a way to get an adult to love
him because the other adults in his life
blew up his life
yeah very very different
even if both of the actions look the
same right
a lying seven-year-old is different than
a lying 30 year old lying's not good but
one of them signals something uh you see
what I'm saying
yes yes so don't put adult
characteristics adult issues into the
heart and mind of that little
seven-year-old
and you opted into this marriage into
this relationship with a guy who had
been on another honeymoon before who
made another human before you did too by
the way
and so don't punish the seven-year-old
for your insecurities for your husband's
past for his crazy ex is a crazy ex-wife
that little seven-year-old doesn't
deserve that you see what I'm saying
okay and the path through that is you
making peace with the relationship that
you chose which is this new marriage
and it's you making peace with you're
enough
does your husband walk around wishing he
had his ex-wife back
okay then don't start don't walk around
you don't walk around that house saying
well he used to have another woman that
he loved don't do that don't do that why
that's just choosing to be miserable
right and I want you to practice doing
new things with this little boy
even when you quote unquote don't feel
like it here's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna send you the questions for humans
for kids okay okay and I want you to
commit to two months that's eight
breakfasts with him in a row so that
there's some sort of routine
and take these cards that's all you have
to do is take these cards just you two
together
um and ask him some of these questions
okay
okay that's it and he asks you you got
to be honest and answer and if he
actually says something funny laugh and
if he comes at you to hug you and his
hands are covered in frogs and worms or
whatever else you can grab his wrists
and say hold on go wash your hands
and you're teaching him
hygiene and hospitality and then you're
going to give him that hug
even though he looks like his mom even
though he looks he acts like his your
husband's EX
because he's just a little
seven-year-old boy wondering
are you gonna leave me too
okay are you gonna leave him
no
I don't want to no no no I don't want to
what's Yoda say there is no try are you
gonna leave him
no okay
rest on that exhale on that I'm gonna be
here
so what does that mean that means I get
to decide what this relationship looks
like moving forward and since I'm the
adult I'm gonna do things even I don't
quote feel like them
I'm gonna I'm gonna use my energy to
connect with this kid this kid is going
to graduate high school and he's going
to have some challenges because the
divorce was a big deal the fighting is a
big deal the back and forth with Mom and
the dad acts all that that's a big deal
but this kid will never Wonder
if I loved him
he's never going to wonder if I would
show up if he needed me
because I'm gonna have laid a path that
he knows exactly who I am and how much
he means to me and you as the adult are
gonna have to practice that
and don't compare him to your daughter
they're never gonna be the same never
gonna be the same and that's okay
thank you so much for the call Tamara
you're brave brave uh stepmom lean into
it